all right
so far
here we go
I'd like to welcome everyone to the
meeting today for the um assets and
infrastructure
um first meeting for the session and
we're looking at the roof at the moment
I'd like to open the meeting first of
all to call for any apologies
um I think we've got David prentist on
the uh Zoom have we
not he comes coming really
no apologies
Joe Stringer yes
no further apologies would someone like
to move with Joe or the apology be
accepted thanks
Richard and Peter Neville
all those in favor of please say aye
against it's great
all right we've got a reasonably long
um agenda but I think most of it's
pretty straightforward
um first of all is the adequacy of
fencing around the material and
oxidation ponds there was a query
brought up at a prior meeting and
there's some photos there showing what
is exists and um if there are any
comments on that
if not
um let that report be received thanks
Brett
a secondary Ben thank you
those in favor please say oh
uh David welcome to the meeting we're
just just kicking off and um you can
hear us all right
thank you
we've just had a comment about the
fencing around the ponds after
um uh querying earlier on and we've
there's some photos there showing the
adequate fencing we've put in since the
um incident
next one is the three Waters update from
the assets and infrastructure committee
um it's quite a long report and it's
Jason like to comment on it
thank you Mr chair uh just the only real
uh comment I'll just take the the report
is read uh in a comment uh or update uh
from a otago South and regional meeting
yesterday was that I understand
um there has been some traction around a
uh chief executive for the for interd
and so I understand that that will be
announced in the near future
um the only other thing maybe would
whether
um
uh uh councilor Jose or chief executive
Mr Perry like to comment in terms of
what any updates from the rural
provincial
foreign
councilor over Illinois as you correctly
pointed out that it's in the rural and
provincial meeting in Wellington uh on
Thursday and Friday last week the
meeting is fair to say that it was
dominated by the events of cyclone
Gabrielle and the impact felt by those
councils that bore the brunt of that
vicious event and so it did dominate
proceedings but a highlight certainly
was the free and Frank exchange of views
with the new Minister
um
who I think brings to the table
a pragmatic sense of authority and
trying to get things done and also a
willingness to listen engage and
certainly from my humble perspective
uh he's it seems to be a guy that has a
reasonable command of his portfolio and
not
um tied to a prepared script and is free
to answer a lot of questions
I guess what I took out of his uh
remarks to the or the um Gathering was
that uh there is going to be some
changes in the three Waters policy space
obviously it's an area of hot with a
high degree of um
uh contention and dissension and around
the country and uh one of the things
that the minister macanulty pointed out
was trying to
any change in the reform process and he
didn't go into details and he actually
did say that Cyclone Gabriel had really
distracted resources or diverted
resources to obviously to where they
were needed and he was hoping to be in a
position to perhaps outline some
proposed changes but that wasn't the
case because of the in the destructive
effect of cyclone Gabriel but what he
did hint at was that he was looking at
changes so that the concerns around loss
of a local voice could be meaningfully
addressed in making some changes to the
uh the proposals that have been widely
uh disseminated and you'd have to argue
widely criticized
um it didn't give too much away apart
from that but you did get the impression
that he's a guy that is
lives in a rural area of New Zealand and
wairarapa he's the MP for waialappa and
has a good handle on the issues around
the country and may mention that he had
previously Williams and Associate
Minister had conducted a tour of all all
councils in New Zealand which took some
three months so we went with interest
but clearly I think there will be some
changes in the current policy setting
but whether they go sufficiently far
enough to appease those that have strong
concerns about what's being proposed as
a mode point
may have more to edit on that point
I thought that summary was very fair and
deals with all the issues thank you
thank you Steve and Keith
um there's one comment there's lots of
increments to get your head around and
there's probably lots of um uh work to
be pushed through before we can hit the
deadline but it'll be interesting to see
if they make it
and there's an election in between
um
was someone moved that that report be
received
thanks Stuart nope any secondary
any more any other comments second to
Richard is it thanks
in favor of this report be received
please say aye
it's cased scared
move on to the de-sludging at the pond
um
as Matt would like to comment on this
one or yes
thank you Mr chairman
um yeah I guess just um I'll take the
reporters read
um but just a bit of an update in terms
of progress on site over the last few
weeks so the containment bun for the
sludge is now
uh fully complete in the de-sludging
contractor is establishing on site as we
speak so
um I guess we're expecting some sluds to
start being removed
um either late this week or early next
week so that's all pretty pleasing
progress
um yeah hippie taking questions on the
report
answer any question from it
I
I do have one as sort of a juggling act
with the money
as does that kind of um
we need to look probably at that at the
wider sphere of also the consent overrun
too whether that
is going to be covered or is that cons
which we'll see in a further item but
sorry you're referring to the consent
renewal yeah project yeah yeah and and
certainly yeah we I guess
um
as part of the the annual plan process
um I guess there's a a chance to look at
things
um from a Global Perspective as to where
our spending is and things like that
it's just that we need this
um need to give the contract of us clear
Direction now
um which doesn't quite align with the
annual plan time frames is probably the
key thing
um let's cause the juggling
coming from case things
I'm not a member of the committee but to
me there's something that doesn't quite
Stack Up
pain the with regard to the additional
funding that has been referred to to
allow further work to be done
what has been described is that the
existing Tower doesn't need to come down
now because we consider that there isn't
the same safety issue
and if that's the case why can't it stay
full stop
secondly it says that there is a saving
to be made because the tower is not
coming down now but we want to spend
that money next year now that's not a
saving nor nor do I believe that this
committee nor Council can actually pass
a resolution that a project we put in
next year's annual plan at this stage
from from my perspective if if the money
is to be
declared Surplus because the tower
doesn't need to come down I think we
need to go through an exercise to see
where the priority lies for spending it
and I'm not 100 certain that it should
be spent on removing sludge given some
other financials that are referred to in
this report
if we could have coming from a financial
advisor
tonight
I used three Mr chair I think the the
issue that the three Waters and asset
manager is Raising is more around the
practicalities of you know this is one
of those ones that needs to be looked at
in isolation in the sense that we've got
a Contractor on site they've got the
ability to take out double the amount
and actually make it future proof the
project a little bit more and save some
funds long term run that being double
the cost and having them back and spend
another 2 million plus inflation why
would we not get double the amount out
and spend another 450 250 000.
um the three Waters asset manager when
he was looking at this had a look at the
program and looked at what he could
defer or push out and that we could look
at other options when it came to annual
plan and and the ltp coming for going
forward F3 Wars was still to be in
Council control in the ltp process but
you know this they they are whilst I
connected they're still the issue at
hand that Matt is referring to is
a time sensitive one
Maybe
I'd like to hear thanks Brett
yeah thanks John just three years to
Matt so
made a path for me and being anecdotal
what is the risk of of us under under
doing their removal of volume like if
looking at the report the volumes
increased significantly over the years
with the um
high level confidence with the
assessments
if we if we go short what are the risk
real risk to council with those plans
through the chair
um so I guess the risk of around the
slud's build up as a decrease in
performance of the ponds and potentially
odor issues
um I think as has previously been
discussed we haven't seen that um
with our treatment plant at this stage
um
and yeah I guess
um with the
the first stage with the already
committed amount of sludge being removed
that's just it's going to be a
significant portion of sludge to be
removed
um
and so I guess the risks will be
relatively low in the short term but
it's more around the medium term
and and how soon we might need to do
that next phase of of de-sludging so
um you want it might be that that we
need to do it much sooner than we think
um and I guess yeah the
um the rail driver behind doing it now
is that as everyone's aware
you know these things the cost
associated with these things always go
up and so if we're back doing more
desludging work and
um in the medium term and we can expect
to pay significantly more
um than what we would have to pay if we
if we do it now
um I guess one thing that I will add is
um we have now received
um
the feasibility assessment for the long
list of options for the Wastewater
consent renewal project and
um
based on that and it obviously it's only
a draft and needs to be put through the
working group and things like that but
it is looking I guess more and more
likely that the oxidation ponds will
form part of the long-term future of
Gore's wastewater treatment
uh which you know I guess is reasonably
significant in terms of
um I've been wanting to remove more
sludge
thanks thanks man yeah
um I suppose the questions have been
posed around priorities to you is this
an absolute priority and your view as
manager of the three Waters area without
confusing the water tower as you put
that to one side
um if it was a additional budget that
was absolutely necessary is this the is
this that priority
uh through the chair it's always a
tricky one because
um you can never quite tell
um you know I guess if you're comparing
it to a say a pipeline that's in bad
condition you never quite know how long
that pipeline is going to last for
but I guess
um
you know our treatment plants both Water
and Wastewater are probably our most
significant assets and
um you know I'd put water at the highest
priority as that provides drinking water
which is you know
probably
um slightly more important but
Wastewater would come with close seconds
in terms of you know if it's not
operating effectively you know we can
have some pretty significant
environmental consequences and um and
you know some there's some legislative
requirements to make sure they perform
well so it is probably right up there to
make sure that
um our wastewater treatment plant is
operating as effectively as possible so
based on that I would say it's a
reasonably high priority yeah
Neville
yes God damn it okay yep
I am
not I actually I'm not sure whether
we're actually looking at this
I've seen since before 7.5
page 19.
for the Department came through the
sentence leads the main reason for
demolishing the town is
I appreciate the problem
out from Nutella
appreciate Department
to minimize our health and seeking risk
is how are they launching
purely
comes down to a health and safety
Progressive and I think from our from
the other side looking
purely from
the lanes of this it looks like we're
potentially de-prioritizing a
significant health safety risk to remove
additional sludge from a home
but I'm not sure that the
two should be considered like that
I think
that's a good question
um we would like to hear from some more
committee members for first yes
level
thank you
I'm on the same uh uh wavelength does
yourself there and
the question I have is um through you
through the two admit is how far through
are we with the changeover from the
pumps from the tower
through the chair
um so there's an update provided and
further on in the gender around that
project so we're now res the design is
largely complete for the pump station
and we've engaged uh contractors for the
pump station relocation
so the next
so the depths in that project would be
to get in a building consent application
right and I'd expect the building to to
probably be underway in the next say six
to eight weeks until they physically
haven't started yet have they no no
that's great so
what iponder is what is the greatest
risk
and I know that we pointed out that the
tower at the moment is a health and
safety risk
but it also it is a great risk if our
ponds aren't desloved properly
um being a ex wastewater operator I
understand the methodology of an
oxidation pond and how bad it can get
really quickly and I don't think that
we've got the opportunity
if we were to have a mishap to be able
to work our way out of it
and the cost alone would be probably
more than what it would be to put in a
tower
so
I think I'm on the on the side of staff
and that that we defer the
the demolishing of the
Tower and that we actually create a a
no-go Zone around the tower by fencing
it
and I think that would probably mitigate
their health and safety risk a little
more than what we have currently and
separate the whole Tower from from the
actual
here we are and I think that would
probably be cheaper in the long term at
the moment that's just a thought
we also have the um three Waters coming
in next year and whether we're going to
have control of this in the 12 virtually
just about 18 months time yeah or even
less yeah well I appreciate that the Geo
I think you'll be continuing to think
about the three Waters coming in all the
time we're never ever going to
get to the Future because at the moment
we still haven't built the reservoir up
there we still haven't got the pumps
changed over we still haven't got the
bridge and the water going across the
main the main from our main water plant
so we've still got a lot of work and a
lot of thinking to do before
uh before anything happens and and yes
we've got to ponder a lot in the
meantime about what is the priorities
because yes we're fast running out of
money
and that's that's a serious thing
yes did it selling is a big issue over
all those projects and being
thank you through your chair I just want
to ask the CFO
um just for clarity next annual plan are
we going to have to find that 450 000
again like if we spend it on the diesel
engine now we're going to have to try
and find that or is that allocated okay
so so we would have to
find that completely right so it's not
just switching projects timelines it is
completely redoing the annual plan to
find the money for the tower again
uh yeah through you Mr chair the because
this is a new a new part it will be
additional so anything we defer will
require additional um for us to find the
money from somewhere else or to increase
rates
[Music]
thanks
okay I just have a question that the
terror has it just got a bit of concrete
falling off it now Nee is it
structurally unsafe
is it going to fall over what I
understand structurally it is very safe
and it's got a good earthquake rating
but it has got problems with concrete
dropping off or scaling of it dropping
off and Frost and wet weather and
hitting somebody on the head of the
standing underneath it yeah that's why
it's fenced off it's not structurally
going to fall over at the moment is that
right Matt
through the chair yes that's right
um yeah so we've previously had a
structural assessment completed on it
which which didn't identify any
significant
um concerns around earthquake strength
but it is that that spool and concrete
from the top of the tower and the
potential debt to fall on someone and
close with some of the end of the Tower
think
Richard
yes just reach achieved obviously
everyone's having a crack at this one
um
when we look at it we've actually got
two two different uh two two separate
things that have merged which is causing
us the issue around the fact that we
have
the uh the tower being merged with
trying to find that money with these
de-sludging I think our councilor
Phillips has probably hit it on the head
we can't ignore the fact that we we have
actually publicly sat here and talked
about a health and safety issue around
one of our
items that are under our control should
something happen we are liable so we do
need to take some action we do need to
do some sort of remedial or uh
barricades pencil type situation to
alleviate that but I do look at the fact
that we
um have the dislodging issue there as
well so I'd be happy to support the
sludging matter but we need to take some
sort of rehabilitative or change action
to the existing structure of the tower
we did recognize that before we've
documented that we've discussed it we
can't ignore that and suddenly decide
we're not going to do anything about it
at all for another year because I think
the liability Factor would be too high
and we've seen that
just a question from it it is fenced Now
isn't it
through the chair yes um there is a I
guess a barricade that's been put up
around it
um and yeah potentially if it was going
to remain for longer we could make that
a bit more permanent as part of that
works one of the main things we did is
we diverted the access road away from
the water tower the access road into the
water treatment plant so there's no
previously there was a requirement to
drive quite close to the tower to get
into the water plant but we've diverted
that road away so there's
um yeah it's reducing the potential for
staff to need to go on in the area
so yeah
probably the the matter is is as if we
have had taken satisfactory steps to
ensure if anything happens
um we don't want to be liable so I have
no issues with the the two merging but
um we have clearly said we have a health
and safety issue on one of our
structures and we need to ensure we've
taken every every means to avert it or
if something happens if we're put placed
under scrutiny we would withstand it
I think someone needs to probably form a
motion that covers if we do do the swap
around we need to have secure fencing
around the tear Ben
so you must check it to further that
point if we were to get to that stage
where we could securely fence it and the
likes of work safe and everyone are
happy how long realistically are we able
to defer the demolition of the Water
Tower or does it really depend on the
con you know the weather conditions over
the next couple of years
or does it really need to be done in the
next year to two years going to be
deferred one year
through the chair I don't believe
we
knew we had their structural assessment
done there was any strict time frames
discussed or raised
um
yeah so I guess that something would
have to look into and consider further
I guess to further that point that the
reality with the current
economic crisis and cost of living is
when we're going to struggle to find
that money this rating cycle with the
impeding rate increase so the likelihood
of getting delayed yet another year is
quite high I would I would imagine
um
yeah or you could just want to make
counts as aware of it I guess would
someone any other counselors that
haven't spoken like to say something
glennis Paul next show
Paul
I just look them yeah
look there's um sorry through the chair
there's you can look at it either way um
it is if it's a health and safety risk
we have got to be seen to be acting on
that
um
it's nice to be able to put stop
something and and work on something
that's actually going to be needed now
which is some diesel engine
um I think the only way you can do is if
you want to move on is is work on that
make a motion with the fence or protect
the area but you've got to work on a
time frame there because we can't put it
off forever can we
if we can well then why are we looking
at this the other thing I'm trying to
think of it doesn't have to be done now
but
I'm happy to go with them through that
as well that's decided thanks thanks
Paul
um any coming
you might have to grab nibbles
just uh
we just I think I can see Matt's point
of wanting to do the whole thing now
because you're established in the actual
cost
uh will be a lot less doing the whole
job now but I think we just need to look
at a
at our health and safety liability like
everyone's instead and make sure the
place is well fenced off
and that we do get the program together
to take this Tower down if it's such a
problem
right damn Brett Brett then cavemen
I just wonder if the way forward is is
without creating a administer of
nightmares to the Tower of prep needs to
be subject to a further report from
staff like we're sitting here today
without the report that was in front of
the council that made the decision that
it was a provided to demolish if there's
alternative health and safety remedies
that can be put in place cost escalation
issues if we delay it but I agree with
the sentiment that the two issues are
probably merged when they're in fact
quite quite separate so that may be a
way of separating the issues and going
forward
okay then
just to comment I have
I'd like to give an example of I know of
a company this is about liability I know
of a company that installed
a bit of Machinery away back in the day
of the labor department
and this piece of Machinery was checked
over by the labor department is safe
a few years later a gentleman injured
themselves really badly on this you know
some of the people will be familiar with
this example
and the owners of that bit of Machinery
got prosecuted big time
even although it had been approved by
the labor department so what I'm saying
is
health and income or somebody like that
might say yes that's fine the way you've
got it done but if something still
happens
they will run away and hide
and say you're still liable
and it's just my point of saying if work
and income said yes that's fine and then
some something still happens
you still liable
thank you thank you I think um it comes
it's looking like we'll need to go to
demotion a bit
um we can read receive the report
demolition of the Hillary wooded chair
be deferred until
24-25 from natural near I think that
needs to be changed and we need to look
at a report on the tower and what we can
do to make it safe
and the final but the budget for the
sludging project be increased by 450 000
for an additional sludge to be removed
from the pond the gore and the treatment
plant for the treatment plant needs to
be thought I think almost postponed do
we get a report on the tear and how soon
we need to knock it over or if we can
make it safe
been I I agree with that I just wanted
to ask Matt in terms of time frames uh
just acknowledging they are de-sludging
now how long have we got to make this
decision
um
yeah I was just thinking that
um yeah I mean the discussions that
we've had with the day sludging
contractor to date have been that we
would be able to give them a pretty
clear steer after this meeting
um so I don't know that we've got a lot
of time to make that decision
be preferable if we could get a decision
at this meeting
um
but I can have another chat to the
contractor
um
and see
yeah see
whether we can defer that decision
um yeah so
oh
um Steve
Mr team I just wonder whether uh to help
the meeting about this this dilemma that
whether you should focus on the need for
de-sludging the oxidation ponds and the
need for increasing the budget
and make a decision on that given that
with the trajectory of three Waters
reform
um the ability for the council to
actually
have a second bar of the Cherry through
the three Waters into the end to further
de sludge may be limited for possibly as
long as five years so I wonder whether
the committee should focus on the merits
of doing a extra D sludge albeit with an
increased budget limit make that
recommendation for Council and then at
the same time uh the three Waters
manager and the general Ranger corporate
support can then report on uh funding or
substitution options which may include
the water tower one may include some
other things
um that might be the best way forward uh
because without that
you've got a prop potentially a lost
opportunity with a contractor on site
and ready to do more work
thanks Steve
um so would someone like to
change a change of motion or do you want
to proceed as proceed as there
have we got any notion
Neville
I'm quite happy with the recommendation
the way it's written that we report the
report that the report be received that
the demolishment of Hillary Ave and
water tower redeferred to 2024
waiting a further report from staff
and that the budget be dislodging
project be increased by 450 000 to allow
additional slugs to be removed from the
Pawn One
Optical wastewater treatment plant
your nipples moving there is there a
secondary
Stewart your second day
all those in favor please say aye
against
carried
Richard
comment just confirming
that motion we've just voted on
um which was rather quick uh
demolition demolition so we're actually
State and stating just clarify we're
stating we are going to defer regardless
that the demolishment of help we have
watertow be deferred to until 2024-25
Financial year and waiting for a further
report from staff that will give us an
indication that maybe we need to go
sooner than 20 25 okay or whatever it
might be all week money all the money
yeah where the money May came from so we
need to tag on that to report yeah yeah
is it is that what we sort of wandering
yeah yeah
three years gym we take it I think the
recommendation wasn't quite that but we
will take it that if the staff will uh
send a report with this minutes with
these minutes to the full Council on
options and respect of how to two things
how we bridge the gap of 450 and address
any health and safety issues in the
interim regarding if the water tower is
postponed
because of course the committee only has
recommendationally powers yeah and the
full Council can if need be finesse any
recommendation before it becomes a
resolution
yes thank you CEO because it seemed to
just we merged we merged to
to the outcomes there that yeah got a
little bit of gray area so just make
sure we record that
figure treatment people happy still with
that motion
um with the addition
and it's still got to be passed by
Council so I think we'll probably end up
going in circles again thanks Brett I
think the minutes will capture the
health and safety aspects of that in the
motion yeah nice to have been in there
but that's certainly in the body of the
comments
thank you no more comments on that item
we'll move on to climate change working
group update
from Jason
thank you Mr chairman uh again this is
just an update for the group I will take
the um
uh the report is read
um this is just on on the basis of work
that has been occurring over the past
sort of four months uh following some
Regional discussions around climate
change as of uh July 2022
um an update on this since
um the writing of this report
the regional climate change governance
group
also met which
councilor Hope Illinois attended uh
and that really is just I guess the
first step in trying to
bring some bring to light some of these
issues around climate change and the the
ever increasing need for us as a region
to be um
working together to address some of
those issues so happy to take any any
questions or if um this councilor Hotel
wants to make a comment I'm sure we will
I just didn't just have one comment
Jason was um the later Lodi report it's
been a long time coming it's a bit like
another report we had for her that was
flowing over for water and we haven't
seen it yet
Keith
before Jason replies on the later
information I attended the meeting as he
referred to and the objective really is
for the territorials and the Regional
Council to work together to have a
common approach to climate change issues
and that will feed into what's required
under the new environmental legislation
as well but at the same time it does not
remove the need for us as a council to
prepare our own climate change strategy
in terms of how the council itself
responds and in terms of some of the
other issues that impact on the district
and that's something that I guess is
part of the district plan review and as
part of the planning or policy and
planning committee will be following up
on those issues
I think any
any comment on this report Jason no just
comment on the lie though yes uh Mr
chairman um it has been a long time
coming
um unfortunately uh something that has
been I guess out of the direct control
of the the councils that have been
Desiring this and it's just been a
schedule that has occurred and depending
on on weather and other bits and pieces
but now that there has been completed we
are hopeful that we can get that
information
um
back to the region and so we can
actually start to use that to form some
meaningful data that can really start to
inform decision making from this point
forward so
um we are again uh just a knowledge that
we are pressing environment South and uh
around that because there's some key in
terms of the key work to come out of
that certainly uh flood modeling
um will be really critical for this
District in terms of
um what uh what we what we can expect
and how we best prepare to um to adapt
to them
thank you any more cleaners
grape case
yes
thank you Mr chair
um there was a carbon
neutral Advantage group set up that did
a lot of work around
um carbon and how we could mitigate that
is that going to merge with this group
because there's quite a lot of data
there that Steve Kenny set up that group
and I was part of that
through the chair
um the uh
Great South in terms of the work they
have done
um will certainly feed into that group
long term
part as you'll see in the report there
one of the the steps for for this
Council will be
um
reporting on our own
carbon footprint or Baseline as it were
and that's a piece of work that we will
be looking to um
undertake as soon as we can but yes
certainly there'll be a
need to work closely with great South
around there and we have had discussions
up to this point about their support
through this process as well
okay
no further comments on that report will
would someone move that that report
received received Paul thanks
and just figured by Stewart
those in favor please say aye
against carried
um next we'll move on to there's a
report from the roading
hang on
three Waters in Road in Bulletin
um
it's information to be received
the only comment I had was the well
levels look alright but how come we ran
out of water in one well
in the Jacobs Town well there's a report
further on to say we're sucking here
yeah
through your chair
um the Dragonstone well that went
um dry or low was our backup Supply we
were doing maintenance on the main well
when that happened we
um got their one followed back up pretty
quickly
yeah
no thanks very much
someone like to move that any other
comments on those reports Roadie and
Richard
just a six and a half percent increase
in the water usage of Matera what does
that equate to is it leaks or uh
people bathing in the street or you know
like the Heat
there's no
no Rhyme or Reason because I see Gore
stayed the same and obviously we're
going through the hospital but matera's
gone up so
councilor Phillips may be able to help
us but
I can make a comment but it's not very
nice
we were concerned that there may have
been leaks
um and we're about to
get the leak detection investigation
team in uh we had one day of rain and
cold weather and consumption drop
so they indicated that it's not leaks
start summer yeah
thank you
great oh discussing both both routing in
here he just threw you Mrs humans the
question to marry on page 30 the The
Pedestrian Crossing on Railway East
Bernard it'd be great to get an update
on that I'll see you've done a some work
for kiwira is there any further
information for
committee
yeah through you Mr chair um so I've
recently
um
got a quote from wsp for the uh for the
design of the um the median that's
required there on the on rowley's plan
itself
um
uh so what I need that for is to take
that to both the um the mountain bike
club and the East Coast call
for consultation
so I'm awaiting a result from that but
our intentions still has to to do that
work before the end of this financial
year
thank you I just asked Kimi Rao was what
was the feedback from Kiri rail around a
piece of work you said you've recently
done a report
to gain approval
a rail Crossing assessment was carried
out uh so the Kiwi roll the
um
keep me around where here there's a
assessment done uh kiwi roll were part
of that assessment along with a
specialist consultant and the outcome of
that was that they approved basically of
the proposed pedestrian Crossing and
that will be further enhanced by the
um the fencing that has been we've
received funding for from the betterment
fund that wasn't a requirement of of qrl
but normally they do require that sort
of fencing so it was a surprise that
they didn't require it but that will
further enhance the the
acceptance of it
indicator
by further comments
pain
just more of a three Mr chair more of a
broad question to Murray um with the
contract uh with Fulton Hogan coming to
an end the road maintenance contract
coming to an end of the 30th September
um and switching to K2 Contracting have
you seen a noticeable change
um in the the maintenance
um either an improvement or a
degradation or is it yeah relatively the
same uh through Mr chair it's probably
pretty similar because K2 were the did
most of the physical work under the
previous contract and the contract
specification is is very similar to the
previous contract
um there is a a slight increase in the
cost of of some of the work but that's
in line with the
um the cost and play cost fluctuation
sort of
um increases that have been experienced
right across the board in the in the
Contracting area so the the standard
um is yeah as a similar of possibly
slightly better but um yeah
thank you
um someone like
move that that Rose reports be received
Richard and Brent seconded those in
favor of please say aye against carried
project register
that's the next on the agenda
um
Matt is going to comment on that
through the chair um yeah I just I guess
um
explain for those that haven't seen this
before that this is a I guess a global
overview of all our three Waters capital
projects and there's obviously a
specific update report for each project
following following on in the agenda so
there's a chance to ask questions about
specific projects as we go through each
individual report
um but I guess from a Global Perspective
there is really quite a lot of uh work
going on at the moment in this in the
capital Works Space for three Waters
um
there's a bit of a struggle to stay on
top of it at the moment and then we're
expecting to be pretty busy for at least
the next six months just making sure
that we do stay on top of all this work
now look looks a bit looks a busy
schedule
and they're saying we're starting to
feel the impact of the traffic movements
from the Main Street already
yeah
um you're just on that too I think it'd
just take the chance I don't know if uh
councils have met but um sitting down
the end of the table by uh Aaron is our
new uh project engineer Terry Trotter uh
so Terry started with us about a month
ago now Tyrion was certainly and so he's
working with Matt to help uh filling in
from the change of roles with Aaron
moving across to operations manager so
it's good to have that additional
resource there also and just to uh nice
to put a name to the face for those that
haven't met Terry already
thank you thanks Jason
um do you want to go flex three days one
by one we'll flip through the reports
then Elizabeth Street service upgrade
getting pretty well through yeah through
the chair yes so um you know
um progress over the last couple of
weeks since I wrote the report um so the
mains and Elizabeth Street are now all
complete and reinstatement of the
of the carriageway will be occurring
over the next couple of weeks and
Elizabeth Street
and then there's just some property
Connections in Joseph Street to be done
um and Fulton Hogan will also be
starting on the construction of the
infiltration base and the intersection
of Elizabeth Street and Broughton Street
possibly in the next couple of days so
yeah it is
um really all sort of coming together
um
well on the project now finally
um and yeah we're slowly working through
the private property separation Works um
I guess the main constraint there is the
availability of the local plumbing
resources so just working through those
as as resources allow
acute
no comments on that one we'll move on to
the
eSchool water trim Planters next one is
it
someone would like someone to receive
that report Richard thank you
signature needle
those in favor please say aye
against it's carried
escort water treatment plant
coming to its really finality yeah
a few
hatches with noise
through the chair yes yep just that um
that noise I showed really the final
thing we need to work through on that
project so
no questions on that
someone like to move so we received that
report thanks Brett secondary
sure
guys in fighter please say hi
okay it's carried
Wickham Street Wastewater main entry
placement quite a major project
for the chair yes
um yeah so as of yesterday work on site
has now started on this project and is
is the geometry possibly seeing some
impacts around the diversion of the
heavy traffic bypass
which will be in place for a few weeks
um obviously you need to try and get
that work done as quickly as possible to
minimize those impacts but yeah
having to take any questions on that
never
thanks Mr chairman um just one thing man
I noticed that the trucks are still
driving right through the Main Street
um completely driving right through
rather than crossing over it
and then going down the back way to the
bridge so they're going right across the
Main Street and then turning at the
police station to the bridge
so maybe you need a bit more signage on
there I think it's correct
three of Mr chair oh
um answer that one so um we've got two
uh detour routes uh the Northbound
traffic is going uh up the full length
of the Main Street and turning at the
police station onto Midway Street and
the southbound traffic is turning onto
River Street the the
um normal heavy traffic bypass and then
turning into mersey Street and coming
out onto the main street at mersey
Street
um
that we we had to do it that way because
the there's quite River Street is quite
narrow
um and there's an issue with um
potential uh potentially uh having
um trucks uh on northbound tracks uh at
the mersey street River Street
intersection uh having to go over the
center line to to turn out of there so
we we split them as as you've just
described
thank you Murray
further coming project
someone would like to remove that re
receive that report
Ben and Stewart those in favor please
say hi
guys scared uh we'll flick on to move
they wore them fridge renewal
de sludging of the mock station plants
we probably actually had a fair old
camera that but
do we need to cover anything else on it
no further comments
someone moves it will receive that
report
from Stuart a secondary
you know Richard the rise in favor
please say aye
okay it's carried
um Gore and material of Wastewater
consent renewals project update
um
through the chair
um yeah so as I mentioned earlier we've
now got the draft feasibility assessment
of the long list options for this
project and that has been circulated to
the technical working group to consider
so we're aiming to have a meeting with
the technical working group in late
March to consider the findings of that
feasibility assessment
and from there we're expecting to be
able to take a recommended short list of
options for further investigation back
to both the elected members of council
as well as the hokanui Rune hunger
leadership group for approval so I'm
expecting that will be sort of around
the late April early may let me bring
that to you for
for approval happy to take any questions
any questions
Neville
just the one question how's the finance
going the budget
through the chair uh
it's
um
up until now it's been fine although we
have been having some discussions with
the consultant around the additional
work that they've had to do for the
feasibility assessment
um
it's only been informal discussions at
this stage and we're expecting them to
provide something more formal in writing
over the coming days
and potentially we'll bring that to the
council or committee sooner rather than
later
because we're sort of looking at about
20 overrun 120 000.
122 20. that's just about though isn't
it that's an estimate yep it's through
the chair yeah so um yeah as I say we
um
we haven't got all the details at this
stage around the cost that of the of the
work that's recently been completed but
as soon as we do we'll look to bring
something to the committee or the full
Council
um I guess on that it is um when we do
get the the identified short list of
options uh that will give us much
clearer indication as to what further
investigation work we need to do around
those options and the costs and time
frames and things like that for the I
guess the second half of this project
leading into
submitting a consent application to
environment South and so we're sort of
at that point where we can start looking
at at you know a more accurate cost to
complete the project over the next sort
of two or three months yeah
just a question I had is whether we've
been the guinea pigs to set the global
standards or are we
fourth at the Forefront of doing it and
why hasn't this been sort of sorted on a
national scale
the chair I certainly wouldn't say we're
the guinea pigs
um and I think
um a lot of this
Wastewater disposal to land has become
more and more common probably over the
last
18 or 15 years
perhaps more common the further north
you go
so perhaps we're the guinea pigs for
um
for the Lower South Island maybe but in
saying that I know that SDC have worked
through some pretty significant consents
recently and and had to go down this
process so yeah it has certainly become
a pretty common
yeah yeah it's correct
Paul
um
David
what are they doing this
really all the details and exercise
questions
to me some stuff when the final options
are put up it should be a relatively
simple
through the chair uh yeah so um
obviously one of the
um
key stakeholders were most significant
key stakeholders in the in the process
as the as the hokane and they are
heavily involved in the working group
um because I can't speak on their behalf
but my impression and understanding is
they're very happy with the process
that's been followed and support
um where we're at at the moment I guess
a bit of an indication
around that will be when we do present
this uh shortlist
recommended shortlist and and um and if
we can get agreement from both the
hokanui runang and leadership team as
well as the elected members then that'll
be a a really good sign that we're
heading in the right direction
thank you Matt
that someone like to move that we
receive that report
sure and secondary
Bridge those in favor please say hi
against miscarried material River
Crossing project update
some gnarly one
yeah three it's here um yeah I guess
since since uh the council last
um considered this at the last council
meeting we've we've been uh working
through uh the community engagement
details and putting together material
for that
um and we're expecting to table a report
at the March council meeting regarding
the community engagement and and the
process that we'll be following for that
if you take any questions any questions
before that reporter
bread
you're probably not a question but just
a note on page 56 just noting that the
process is likely to take us to the
point that we need agreement with Dia as
to where we go do we understand what it
looks like yet or not
through the chair
uh not specifically at this stage yeah
um and I think the time to have those
discussions would would be when we have
a clear preference as to a bridge versus
a pipeline and then we can I guess have
a bit more meaningful discussion around
what what the approval process is going
to look like
I think we're just gonna um await as the
community discussion goes through I
think and keep your ears and eyes opened
and listen to people and their thoughts
is there a
recommendation we receive that report
so I wanted to move there
Stuart and Neville guys in favor please
say aye
okay it's carried
um material Water Treatment Plant
upgrade
it's through the chair
um
yeah so there's obviously um this is
obviously another quite significant
important project that we've got on at
the moment
um
the contractor is now well and truly
established on site and making
reasonably good progress
it's a lot to start a lot is starting to
happen on site which is which is
pleasing to see a lot of materials and
Equipment now turning up on site really
for installation
a couple of the more significant things
that will be happening over the next few
weeks is the replacement of the McKelvey
Heights tanks
so that will require short shutdowns to
that area of antara while they do a
temporary change over to a temporary
water supply while they install the new
tanks
um and the other significant thing as we
get into the stage where once the peak
summer demand period has passed
um we'll be taking
one of the filters out of service to
start the the filter refurbishment which
is a major component of the project
um and um and yeah I guess the key thing
for that is we've got to wait for the
peak summer demand period
um to pass so that we can be sure that
we can keep up with the water demand
while only operating off a single filter
happy to take any questions on it
any questions on the material nibble do
you take a keen interest
uh thanks Mr chairman um no I just
congratulate the staff are starting well
done
it's been a long process
um just that perhaps where we might need
a little bit of publicity we haven't
seen seen much about
um
to let the material residents know
what's happening in material you know
like we're spending significant amount
of money and upgrading their water plan
and the reasons why we're doing it so
perhaps a bit of publicity
wouldn't give us right probably
no good good comment Neville pass that
onto Sonya
um
would someone like to move that the
report we received from Material water
treatment plant
again and it's Richard
favorite please say hi
guys carried
um unless we're getting down Albury Ave
Water Tower
demolition project we've had a fear old
girl this one's I think
not too much to comment on Mid as if
through the chair yeah so I guess just
as I
um indicated earlier in the meeting and
we've now engaged contractors for the
various aspects of the pump station work
um and um
he'll expect to get a building consent
application submitted sooner rather than
later how many months that's processed
we'll start the the construction of the
building works there's potentially a way
bit of enabling works that we can get
underway in the meantime but once we've
got that building consent we'll be
sort of
um once we get that it'll allow the Full
Construction Works to get underway
so basically we haven't engaged a
contractor for demolition though have we
no no no that's correct
um yeah the plan was to get reasonably
well progressed around the pump station
relocation
um so that we've got certainty around
time frames and things
um before we go out to Tinder for the
demolition works thank you
any more comments on it
we look forward to a report on how we're
going to make it safe
um someone like to move that report be
received
Brett
and a secondary Stuart Rosen favorite
police AI
against carried
um three Waters
monthly compliance reports assets and
infrastructure
to remove all the projects
yep
so three YouTubers
I mean first of all I think we should
have made it for the
well then the parade of the block we can
put on pressing on what is up I think it
wasn't a lot of update in all the
projects but at least fantastic score
the union comment earlier but there's a
huge amount of work coming up it's in
front of you particularly because the
question I'm going to do is one of the
two or three things
that you just consider all of the
projects
yeah
uh through cheer
um is it the kids
um
yeah I mean it is it is just that making
sure
um that we've got
um we're putting enough attention into
where it needs to be we're I guess we
are having to prioritize and pick and
choose where we spend our time and and
that sort of thing obviously having
Terry come on board
um so he wants he gets up and running
will be a big help but it's it's making
sure that yeah we we do we're we're
across things
sufficiently to make sure that we have
have got a good understanding of of any
risks or potential issues so that we can
try and deal with them before they
um
get too out of control
and I guess the other thing is is
probably
um the the mattar rubber Crossing
project and and getting a firm strategy
in place for that
um because that obviously
um as well as allowing
the whole of God have compliant drinking
water it also means that we can get on
uh with the both the Hill breev Tower
Demolition and the replacement of the
Hill breev
Reservoir which is an in pretty poor
condition
um so it would really be good to get
some certainty around that that River
Crossing project and what we're going to
do there
does that cover what you after David
[Laughter]
you know
across all these projects we will have
limited resource base on the free water
I just think it's super important to
look
super important Financial
sport to ensure that this Project's a
little long time for us so if Mark is
saying that he's comfortable then but
yeah
Jason yeah I think just to add to that
and that probably is probably the other
thing that we've we have been discussing
is the the ability to deliver these on
time and on cost you know the the the
market
and the challenges that we face around
these projects
um you know certainly is putting a
significant amount of pressure on the
team but um again of Matt's doing a
fantastic job with that but um again we
will be I think in terms of where we set
we will just try and be open and
transparent with Council as we can with
how the projects are
are moving and but yeah there's
certainly is pointed out it's a it's a
massive workload and yeah I just want to
reiterate you know the work that Matt
has done to this point in this and what
lies in front of us over this next year
again with the transition of three
Waters around the corner
thanks man
just met I'd congratulate Matt and
during keeping all this all together
I think he's doing very well
I just could always add a quick comment
as well just in terms of that that
transparency and communication it's a
massive juggling act and I also commend
you for the amazing work that you're
doing but if you do feel like those
balls are going to drop um and I know
Jason will keep us well on the loop but
that is something that Council needs to
know so we can try and um desperately
find extra resource or whatever we need
to do to help you out to make sure those
projects um do get delivered on time and
into the best quality so
thanks Bean
um go back to Aaron
I know it looks like the new treatment
plants pumping out plenty of information
uh thank you
um these reports are a new requirement
under tomato Roi for our monthly
compliance that we must submit at the
time we're writing this report
um
the monthly reports were still being
developed so there are some some errors
in there so at the next committee
meeting they'll be all up now the
reports
happy to take any questions
Brett
thanks John just through you
um too Aaron just what is the risk to
council with non-compliance because
there's good explanations given
um where's that does it lead anywhere or
is it is it um
case of being aware
this report is is more just a case of
being aware and if we are looking like
we're going to be going non-compliant
for those plants
um
for Hillary Ave where would as noted in
there we're not even attempting protozoa
compliance because the plant's not up to
it the material Water Treatment Plant
upgrade will bring that in line with the
drinking water standards so
um it's going to make a huge Improvement
for the material residence
just one comment was the gray from page
73 the red line one I just couldn't get
my head quite around that one
uh that was just to prove that uh we
were compliant and it was a reporting
issue
um on the reports being developed
when someone
um and further comments on that would
someone like to move that this report we
received
yep
I'm just just a question for you to to
lornay was this the area where an
auditing risk where we we had issues
with the Auditors around uh
quality of the information as opposed to
the outcome of the information is this
starting to move towards satisfying that
area Illinois
uh three years to share partially
um so part of the resp part of the
issues we had with the autism was around
response times and the data entry so it
was a purely a small data entry ERA with
the timing of entering the information
into our CRM system which is our
customer request management system
and effectively what happens what was
happening was the bnfrs call or a
weekend call and the staff will get it
on a Monday to enter the information
into the system and they would enter
incorrectly into the Monday's date
rather than Saturday's date so I was
just making sure we're going back and
checking those dates there around
around the capture of the customer
requests and the time so this is this
does lead into some of the some of the
um some of the some of the measures but
the ones that they had an issue with
were around customer requests and data
entry this is one here's more around the
protozoan agreements compliance with
with those so it's again the the stand
once said down by the New Zealand drink
drinking water standard there's a set of
I think five or eight Maybe
I can't remember off the top of my head
it's not my not my full day
um but yeah there's a there's a set of
about eight there that uh sit down by
the New Zealand drinking water standards
that we have to report on and these
These are part of that but not part of
the ones we got pinged for
thank you thank you
um
I think have we moved that report no
someone like to move that report then
Brett and the secondary Stewart who's in
favor please say hi
okay it's carried I'd like to close this
part of the meeting and um we'll move
into publicly
excluded would someone like to move that
Ben Finke and Richard those in favor
please say hi